now chip green that three comes off Lord
pass Janice he released after the
dealership attempt Dennis needles and
Jana scores a beautiful assist at
touchdown pass from Chris middle another
turnover forced by the Bucs right under
the basket
he dug himself to the deck finding his
helper out of the break yeah let's take
a nap probably about right about done
for the night it might as well throw a
little windmill down hey coach bud saw
the way you came down and said all right
that's enough come on out from behind
Middleton knocks it away from patches
ahead for Chris porzingis is there the
lead pretty honest on the flush
beautifully time passing Chris attacking
the rim like you're supposed to do
selling it like he's gonna take it
[Music]
[Applause]
getting down the Bucks is offensive
efficiency well it's pretty simple as
you see honest flush
[Music]
yes
down off the basketball before the red
light comes on
[Applause]
yes he did I told you it was good Wow
whoa where's up on the honesty honest
tight together love horsing to throw
away let's oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
2189 in less than 30 seconds Mars his
first two points with the Milwaukee
Bucks - the spin move little gather and
then throw it down on him
[Music]
since Yanis trilling siakam not quitting
on the play and it's not out of here
[Applause]
let's go getting downhill great pasty
honest and a hammer finish for a
pinnacle info that's its third and the
previous play Bledsoe went down the lane
and scroll with the right hand this time
draw all the defendants his way and it
drops it off beautiful fine but a Greek
freak you didn't know the freaks come
out at night ahead for heel back for
Yanis what up guy resided a combo and
George Hill beautiful basketball first
two great defensive play give me that
cp3 get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass no-look number from George
Hill and then get out the way in fact
boy swayin
Monster Jam mean bug I had
another take away one knife through soft
butter right about that
[Music]
[Applause]
hammer be honest and I'm 24 Milwaukee
it's exciting when there are multiple
teams do oh my that's exciting
she's every night of the season I mean
look there's no way Vikas he could have
had any idea what was about to happen
giannis triple team get Ito who puts it
comes Blitz out for the Bucks
[Applause]
Marie bye-bye Connaughton to weigh
athletes in this game do not sleep on
cogs eaten he will strike you out or
dunk on you that's been a very sort of
second game as a blazer for Carmelo
Anthony ten point lead
oh man look at this play baseline spin
reverse dunk
[Applause]
[Music]
they're reviewing the problem
[Music]
Oh Kylie has been called for his second
personal foul
when is it anybody to lead and they have
the worst defensive field goal
percentage at that range also so it's
definitely an area
[Applause]
those Jana said you know license I know
how to get those back Danny does it
swell five but lucky
bleeding's New York
[Applause]
17 points here he comes
yes
backside clear it out and then this one
here man this leg needs a four-point
play at a time for George Hill he rips
the three-point land and you rate this
is like almost a full point line just
past half court gorgeous jords that is
gorgeous and intact to Connaughton jana
sees a three man defensive law
Milton back - yes
here's Janice right here you talk about
that wall where here's a little
Wallbanger my name ain't harvey many
tickets remaining for that game tomorrow
night
so get on
great deep bad Swedish to that George
Hill
I hammer these under 29% from the
three-point line deceased could pass I
guess Janice loves it
even Chen's Oh stunt giving that day his
first points in the game
[Applause]
and again Jim Boylan streak against
Chicago in the 52 switch Edwards to the
Old Town Road stratified that saddle to
get to the hotel road keeps at high heat
still there to block
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is it that had the great tip in
Chicago here he gets down the middle and
you give him a chance to take off with
two feet with this explosion Fox watch
Giles Lopez was planning off Harry and
he missed the shot here's blood soon
[Applause]
run out basket Wesley Matthews the game
tied at a dozen it's a layup oh that's
right they have their dunk contest let's
get deep in the nines to run for the
Bucks they would have stuff Oh Ian said
he had six so it is out of sin
a season high for the box
[Applause]
[Music]
about wonder if he said go up it flush
it Kiyo
Lopez absolutely shuts down - Mira
a good play I thought Bradley Beal no
way he's got to give this up but he's
got a wide open ruin camera
Rudy translates into fortress
Lopes storming the gates here good
effort Davis the steal ahead rejected ah
dead a couple just come tallest
Jefferson but Shay is putting his mark
on this game and he missed everything
that a couple the other way
swing it even chin JP slide reverse
windows D Vincenzo acrobatic with six
percent that's spinning in your show
Prince of rebound off the Miss that
petticoat post pins gets inside and
finishes it's coming into play it's just
the lack of chemistry so that these guys
who you know we rarely play together
practice nice doubt the man says I guess
he stops Mason Plumlee
the rim patient back out there for the
bunch Michael Porter Jr is a nice job
reporter Jr never saw that coming
[Music]
[Applause]
sterling brand with authority Tam at
10:09 in the second quarter forty one
thirty Denver